les cerveaux des Shadoks il ne
comportait ton retour que quatre cases
pour les cases étaient pleines il y
avait plus de place et le Shadok on ne
pouvait plus rien lui apprendre si on
essayait quand même alors
obligatoirement il y avait une case qui
se vidait pour faire de la place
de sorte que quand Shadows avec une tête
pleine voulait apprendre quelque chose
il fallait qu'il en oublie une autre
exemple si un Shadok avait appris à
marcher avec une case et que plus tard
il est appris trois mots avec les trois
autres cases et bien si en plus on
voulait lui apprendre à faire du vélo le
Shadok ne savait plus marcher
comme il n'avait que quatre cases
évidemment les Shadoks ne connaissaient
pas plus que quatre mots c'était gabusoé